that's not the plan
what's it like not being black and being
in a group called black honesty
I mean I'm Cuban so like right but not
black
you're not Afro Cuban
deep deep in the spirit okay you know
like I approach life with like soul and
like you know I mean how are you black
on the inside too bro I mean I I don't
know I I bought An ancestry kit I gotta
spit in the tube and send it out we'll
see I'm definitely a lot of
Europe or Ireland I think I'm Irish
German I thought Italian for some reason
I mean I could be wrong I have no idea
polish
I dated a Polish girl in high school her
dad was so [__] racist that sounds
about right yeah yeah sounds crazy
what's your manager over there he looks
like he could be from [__]
Scandinavia
that [__] looks like he's
related to Nicola jokic bro he looks
like yeah he looks like he just want a
chip over there
me and him grew up together we were in
music school in sixth grade shout out to
Jersey yeah bro see how far is uh what
part of Jersey is it planes where's that
in terms of like where The Sopranos took
place and then New York City uh that's
about 40 minutes from Bergen County
where The Sopranos took place and then
there's like because I've only been I
just was in uh where did we go to shoot
with um what's that kid's name just got
out of prison that we shot a shot with
in Jersey
[__] I'll be I'll he's on Empire
yeah we were in some some neighborhood
in Jersey
well we're uh Jersey City or Newark or
some [__]
I lived in Newark for a long time I
definitely texted drusky when I was
there and I'll tell you right now
because I was like I'm in Jersey is he
is he from Jersey
yeah which Drew ski are we talking about
I was in uh Jersey City Jersey City is
that where we were
yeah yeah Jersey City play wild out
there there was like a small it was a
different area we were in the
oh yeah he took he took uh well and he
took uh he bought a honey pack right did
he put the honey pack in the honey bun I
don't know
you guys ever have a honey pack no I
don't even know what that is really what
is a honey pie from the gas station it
makes your dick hard he put a honey pot
and a honey bun
a magic honey you know what else makes
your dick hard Bluetooth go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
bootleg right now sign up you get a
month supply for free I've been seeing
that [__] same active ingredient as Vira
and Cialis and if you use the promo code
bootleg right now you get 30 days for
free that's amazing that was that's
crazy that was like The Truman Show yeah
well you know if you go to the gas
station they have like the magic packs
of honey
and then they also have like the Rhino
pills the Blue Rhino I don't be in that
section it's it's where you check out
yeah like the horny goat weed and all
that all that [__] no it's the it's the
magic honey
really I should have you look if you're
like drinking and you're like look you
know I'm a little drunk I might have
whiskey dick yeah do this or you go to
bluetooth.com keep a blue trolling deck
and use the promo code bootleg and get a
month supply for free
yo
[Laughter]
um that is crazy I was gonna say for you
like uh you know because because the
bending record what came out last year
right the last hour
um what's it like getting on a you know
kind of getting one of the elite MCs in
this [__] to to bless because that's the
record George was on too right yeah yeah
what was that process like you guys are
both obviously I guess well he's on Def
Jam now but you know label Made issues
in fact yeah I mean the Common Thread is
definitely Nema like he's he's [__]
damn near Steve Nash at this point bro
like definitely a Steve Nash type of guy
yeah he's crazy like
um I linked up with Benny and we had
just followed each other on Instagram
and we had spoke
um both East Coast [__] so I feel like
the the Synergy was already there
um but once Nema got involved and just
made it happen it was pretty easy he did
it real quick he killed it you're pretty
big on a lot of the Griselda [__] all of
it yeah yeah Conway is probably my
favorite there Benny Conway is my
favorite everybody I mean I love all
those guys but Conway's [__] [__] rap
his ass off bro and he like makes you
feel like you're like damn I want a
produce for him that's that's probably
the main person what do you produce on
closet prox logic yeah so you've been
doing that for a minute because I feel
like anybody who does [__] on logic like
that's what they learned on and that's
just what they're on like I can't move I
started in 2015 and I looked at Ableton
and that [__] looked like [__]
airplane yeah Ableton Ableton like I
feel like when you look at Ableton it
looks very intimidating right yeah it
just doesn't make sense the interface to
me like you know
yeah exactly it doesn't make sense to me
at all yeah like logic makes sense facts
yeah Pro Tools makes sense
but even Fruit Loops you'll look at it
and you'll be like oh I see what they
did there
yeah
she'll see Pro Tools or you'll see Fruit
Loops and you'll be like I see it I get
it no but Ableton is the one where
you're the cycle this [__] looks like
[__] yeah it doesn't make sense
trigonometry bro yeah you know what I
mean like physics
I feel like if I learned how to use it I
would be such and then I don't
understand the touch thing like there's
like the big thing they sell and it's
just got 800 buttons like what do I do
with this no yeah it's not practical no
and I'd be seeing like shots of the
people on Tick Tock shooting fake
producer videos your [__] NPC ain't
hooked up I'm full of [__] you're just
pressing buttons the Beats already been
made yeah you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah and then there's the DJs
who like there's nothing plugged in like
what are we doing here like bro I ain't
gonna lie I've done that a couple times
with the Beats I did a DJ set where the
whole [__] was done in logic already oh
you just press play just press play and
I was up there on my Denzel [__] it goes
but you know what that's at least I
respect that because you at least put
the set together yeah oh the transitions
was crazy and a lot of um a lot of the
bigger EDM DJs that's what they do but
they do it in Ableton oh yeah yeah yeah
I've watched like I won't say their
names but like in Vegas I've watched
like some of the biggest
DJs in the world just their computers in
Ableton session yeah and they just press
play I mean they're moving with knobs
yeah hey
look
yeah uh you guys got any tour stuff on
the way yup let me start in September
doing us and Europe Canada are you guys
excited to go out
yeah sure that's where we Thrive for
sure so is it just YouTube you guys
bring a full full band yeah I feel like
the full band is definitely like
especially it's got to be the key man
because I feel like when I first saw the
roots I was 12. wow and I was like this
is the craziest show I've ever seen like
a hip-hop band like you know I mean
obviously there's been more incarnations
of that since I was 12. but at the time
when I was 12. It was kind of crazy to
see right yeah so I love to see the
younger like kids feel that for the
first time when we dropped black vintage
a lot of those kids [__] with it a lot
it was reminiscent of outcasts and
Kendrick so they came to the show but
they hadn't they have been going to
other shows so they hadn't seen like of
Us come out and they're doing full
orchestrated you know run through the
whole show so I was gonna say for the
type of music you guys are making I feel
like there's definitely like a huge Lane
now as to where maybe when you first
started or even like three or four or
five years ago it was kind of like an
underground Niche Lane as to where now
like guys like the soul action radio
guys have kind of there's like this Lane
of just like great soulful music that is
finally kind of coming to the Forefront
you know what I mean we're still trying
to find our tribe too bro like it's
difficult with this kind of music
because it's not applicable to like the
quick [__] like Tick Tock it's not gonna
work there
oh man like it's it's not necessarily
like prone to go viral it's definitely
something that people have to you know
ingest that's why the live show is
important right exactly but then the
question is like how do you get more
people to to get to the live show so
we're still trying to find our tribe I
mean our fan base has grown tremendously
you know on a global level in the last
the the two years that black odysses
existed to the world but um we're still
trying to like crack that code you feel